لكن ننتقل الان الى مراسل الجزيره هاني
الشاعر في رفح لرصد الموقف الميداني هناك
ايضا
هاني نعم حسن رفح ليست بعيده عن العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في خان يونس حيث نرى
بالعين المجرده سحب الدخان الكثيفه ربما
ما تحدث به مؤمن سابقا من قصف من قبل
المدفعيه والطائرات الحربيه يسمع بشكل جيد
من هذه المنطقه المرتفعه ايضا اصوات اطلاق
النار يسمع ايضا بشكل جيد وهذا الاطلاق هو
في المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه لخاني وس وهي
تبعد فقط بضعه كيلومترات عن مناطق نزوح
السكان ل المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه من
مدينه رفح جنوبيه قطاع غزه هناك مشاهد
قاسيه رايناها بالعين المجرد صباح هذا
اليوم على الطريق الساحلي جراء نزوح عشرات
الاف الفلسطينيين من جامعه الاقصى التي
كانت مركزا للايواء لنحو 50,000 من
النازحين فضلا عن مشفى الخير ومناطقه
مجاوره كانت يفترض انها مناطق امنه قد نزح
السكان اليها في وقت سابق من شرقي خان
يونس ومن مناطق عده في وسط وشمالي قطع غزه
الى هذه المنطقه لكن تفاجئوا صباح هذا
اليوم بالقصف المدفعي والجوي العنيف الذي
ايضا صمع صداه هنا في مدينه رفح جنوبي
قطاع غزه هذا الامر ادى الى حاله نزوح
كبيره
وبالتالي هؤلاء الان يفترسون الطرقات لان
رفح ب كما يعلم الجميع هي ممتلئه تماما
بعشرات الاف النازحين الذين ما زالوا
ينزحون تبا نعم من وسط وجنوبي قطع غزه وهم
الان بحاجه الى مراكز ايواء تاوي هؤلاء
وبالتالي هم الان يفترشون الطرقات من امام
المنتزه الاقليمي في منطقه المحررات شمالي
مدينه رفح حتى الحدود مع مصر جنوبا هناك
عشرات الالاف الان على الطرقات بحاجه الى
ايواء لان هذه الاماكن قد امتلات وايضا في
مقابل ذلك سيارات الاسعاف تعمل تباعا على
انتشال الشهداء واجلاء عشرات من المصابين
الى مشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف الجار في رفح
وكذلك المشفى الكويتي نقل هؤلاء من محيط
جامعه الاقصى غربي خان يونس لان هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه عمليات عسكريه وبالتالي
يصعب تحرك سيارات الاسعاف من مجمع ناصر
الطبي في خان يونس والخروج الى هذه
المنطقه او الى هذا المكان تحديدا مع
تاكيد السكان هناك وفق اتصالات هاتفيه
وروايات بان هناك عشرات من الشهداء
والجرحى في الطرقات في محيط مستشفى الخير
وايضا جامعه الاقصى ومنطقه الدهره في مخيم
خان يونس وايضا المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه
لمدينه خانيونس حيث منطقه قزان رشوان وهي
ملاصقه الى حدود رفح من الناحيه الشماليه
وهناك غارات مكثفه
وقصفاً مدينه خان يونس عبر الطريق الساحلي
وهو الممر الوحيد الذي يمكن للمواطنين ان
ينق ان ينقلوا عبره الجرحى والشهداء من
هذه المنطقه الساخنه في هذه الساعه بفعل
القصف الجوي والقصف من قبل الطائرات كنا
ايضا قبل قليل في المنطقه الواقعه بين خان
يونس ورفح في المنطقه الساحليه شاهدنا
ايضا طائرات مروحيه تطلق النار وتقوم
باطلاق عدد من الصواريخ صوب المنطقه
الغربيه لمدينه خان يونس وهي منطقه
المعارك تحديدا الواقع في محيط جامعه
الاقصى وايضا شاهدنا السنه الدخان متصاعده
من تلك المنطقه وشاهدنا هروب جماعي وفرار
من نيران هذه الحرب ومن نيران هذه المعارك
الدائره في هذه المنطقه باتجاه مدينه رفع
هناك روايات قاسيه استمعنا لها من قبل
السكان الذين تركوا الخيام وراءهم بفعل
القص في هذه المنطقه وايضا سيارات الاسعاف
تواجد صعوبه كبيره في الوصول لهذه المناطق
ايضا سيارات الاسعاف التي تنقل المصابين
تواجه صعوبه كبيره حتى في التوجه الى
مدينه رفح لان الطريق مكتظ بالنازحين
وبمرك بات النازحين بالتالي تضطر الى نزو
سلوك بعض من الطرق الالتفاف ومن ثم التوجه
للطريق الساحلي بعد ذلك تسلك منطقه تل
السلطان المقتضى بالنازحين وهذا الامر
يؤدي الى تاخر مركبات الاسعاف في الوصول
الى مشافي مدينه رفح وهذا يفقد حياه بعضا
من هؤلاء الجرحى حياتهم وهم الان في اعداد
الشهداء بفعل هذا التاخر الكبير في وصول
مركبات الاسعاف وسلوكها هذا الطريق الخطر
والوحيد وهو الممر الساحلي في المناطق
الغربيه ايضا كانت هناك غاره قبل نحو
ساعتين من الان على مركبه مدنيه في
المنطقه الشرقيه الجنوبيه لمدينه رفح
بالقرب من حي السلام وهناك اصابه تم
اجلاؤهم ووصلت الى مشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف
النجار في مدينه رفح هذه الصوره حتى
اللحظه فيما تعلق بالعمليه العسكريه في
خان يونس وايضا حركه النزوح المتواصله حتى
هذه الساعه بعشرات الالاف الى مدينه رفح
جنوبي قطع غزه هنا حيث يعني النزوح
المتواصل من مدينه خان يونس طيب وانت
تتحدث اشرت الى
انك تبعت مشاهد قاسيه على الطريق من خان
يونس الى رفح في في اي
اطار ذكرت ذلك
هاني نعم يعني هو في اطار مسلسل النزوح
الذي لا يتوقف وما زال الفلسطينيون
يتجرعون مراره هذا النزوح للمره الخامسه
والبعض منهم للمره العاشره ربما هؤلاء ي
هنا مشاهد قاسيه لان القوات الاسرائيليه
قد هاجمت مراكز اللواء بشكل مباغت دون
سابق انذار ودون ان تعطي حتى اشارات
ميدانيه او كما كان في السابق عبر القاء
منشورات او اتصالات هاتفيه بالخروج من هذه
المناطق والتوجه الى مناطق تقول اسرائيل
بانها مناطق امنه في جنوبي مدينه رفح
تحديدا وبالتالي فوجؤوا هؤلاء السكان بان
القذائف تسقط على جامعه الاقصى وعلى
مستشفى الخير ومنطقه حي البراق الواقع في
الحي الجنوبي لمخ خيم خانيونس ومنطقه الحي
النمساوي ومنطقه نهر البارد ومنطقه بطن
السمين وقز رشوان وهي احياء جنوبيه تقع
جنوب مجمع ناصر الطبي هذه مناطق كانت
ممتلئه بالنازحين واعتقد السكان بان
التوجه الى هذه المناطق في اوقات سابقه
انها مناطق امنه لكن عندما وصلت الدبابات
بشكل مفاجئ وقام باطلاق النار ليس نيرانا
ليست نيرانا تحذيريه بل نيرانا قاتله ادت
الى سقوط ضحايا وسقوط ايضا عدد كبير من
الجرحه البعض منهم نقل والبعض الاخر لم
ينقل حتى هذه اللحظه من الطرقات ومن داخل
ال المنطقه الواقعه غربي مدينه خان يورس
حتى ان مدرسه المواصي تعتبر واحده من اهم
مراكز اللواء في المنطقه الغربيه لخان
يونس جنوبي قطع غزه تعرضت ايضا لغار وقصف
من قبل المدفعيه الان طريق المحررات الذي
كان يسلك السكان من المنطقه الوسطى وخان
يونس الى مدينه رفح للنزوح اصبح خطرا
وبالتالي الالتفاف الان عبر الطريق
الساحلي والطريق الساحلي الان هو في مرمى
نيران القوات الاسرائيليه سواء من
الدبابات او من الطائرات او و عبر
المقاتلات التي تشن غاراتها بشكل مكثف في
المنطقه الغربيه المشاهد القاسيه التي
رايناها كانت ناجمه عن ما راه هؤلاء
النازحين من عمليات قصف وقتل واطلاق للنار
على البعض منهم وادى ذلك الى م الى
استشهاد عفوا عدد من هؤلاء وما زالوا في
داخل جامعه الاقصى ومحيط جامعه الاقصى وهي
منطقه نزح اليها كما استلفنا سابقا نحو
60,000 من النازحين وفق معطيات اوليه في
داخل مبنى الجامعه وفي مبنى هذه الجامعه
التي تتواجد في محيطها الدبابات
الاسرائليه في هذه اللحظات